the great out-of-doors
restful calm majestic there's nothing
like it to give you the feeling that
it's great to be alive everyone shares
in the feeling everyone that is except
it wrongly heed has a problem no it
isn't Marian his wife
it's this
know what's making that noise what's
more he's afraid to find out why he's
scared it might be something serious and
his fear has frozen his judgment he
knows something is the matter with the
edge but because he's scared of what it
might be he won't admit anything's wrong
that's what a simple fear can do here
are some other things it can do it
what's that noise noise what noise Ed's
not really an idiot he's simply denying
the source of anxiety pretending there's
nothing there
fear can also make us project the
anxiety try to laugh at all it's a kind
of nuts not not not oh I did it
knock knock who's there Marion Marion
boo Marion haste repent at leisure haha
or if that doesn't work there's the
camouflage called icy disdain why don't
you go back to Glasgow Swaraj
now here you're just being stubborn just
the way you are about your stomach
trouble over the line out loud all for
you and that was the last refuge in
ducking the issue anger unreasoning
anger but you can't drive away anxiety
about your car or your stomach by denial
sarcasm or tank there are always
reminders
forget it and there comes a time when
it's impossible to ignore the trouble
any lon so you may want advice it's easy
to get looks bad once they start to go
it's curtains valve lock going to Cape
cher yeah reporte widget fittings my
brother-in-law had the same trouble
blowing the head is now more confused
and worried than he was before but
what's this hmm save expensive repair
bills recondition your own motor results
guaranteed
well there are the results and they're
guaranteed no will you take it to class
knows it well
I'll tell you what I do Mac I placed on
a road aways a fella named a cry got a
special system for taking a motor down
save his dough
this is Clyde got a special system for
taking a motor apart will way shape my
figure Jack interpret king size ring
flanges demo distillate pop suppressors
and militating mode II didn't save a
dime by going to Clyde
too bad mr. Parmalee we she brought it
in when the trouble first started now
well here's the tariff we replace it
what's the matter mr. Parmalee something
bothering you
yes something's bothering head his
stomach as Marion said it's been on the
blink for a couple of weeks now
again heads were eaten scared worried
that his indigestion might be something
serious and scared to face the problem
so when the subject comes up why do you
take that stuff all the time in he uses
the same bag of tricks in denial what do
you mean I don't take it all the time
laughing it off I don't think it does
you any good well well the Florence
Nightingale of Blake Street we were
talking about your stomach
I see disdain
and finally anger ed and I we should go
and see a doctor get out just a minute
in huh you're being pretty difficult you
know I'm being difficult right the same
as you were about your car oh you know
your body's a lot like your car motor
except that it's a little harder to buy
new parts for it when your motors in
good shape it runs like this when
something goes wrong and usually gives
you a warning your body usually gives
you a warning too when it does it's best
to pay attention and do something about
it
do something my medicine cabinet is
loaded with stuff Edie
using that in your stomach is like using
this in your engine it's dangerous
look it you've had indigestion for more
than a couple of weeks
remember that signboard it's something
that could mean cancer yeah
well I might as well give up then like
the fellas were saying just the other
day cancer once it starts in its
curtains runs in the family
and take us to my wife's uncle had it
bluey you've heard amateur diagnosis
before you ought to know what it's worth
nothing Oh what can I do very simple get
your clothes up and go right now to see
a doctor yeah yeah it's perfectly right
and normal to be afraid of cancer cancer
is an enemy but you don't fight it by
getting panicky instead you take
positive action you go to a man who has
the weapons to fight the enemy wait a
minute
and and that's not the man remember
Clyde the mechanic with a special system
this is the same type of operator as the
only man to trust is a recognized
physician
Edd's still pretty nervous all right mr.
Parmalee you're always more scared of
something you know nothing about and it
has a lot to learn about cancer here are
the facts cancer is not contagious
cancer is not hereditary cancer is
curable thousands of Americans are cured
of cancer every year by one or more of
three recognized cures surgery x-ray and
radium you see a cancer is a group of
cells within your body whose growth is
uncontrolled and very rapid at first the
cancer may be localized but unless its
growth is checked quickly it spreads it
may spread this way by direct extension
or which is even more dangerous it may
spread like this with cells leaving the
main part of the cancer and entering the
bloodstream to lodge and grow in other
parts of the body this is called
metastasis
it can happen to a cancer at any time
when it does the problems of locating
and attacking the cancer are greatly
increased cancer must be found and
treated before it extends too far or
metastasizes early examination is half
the battle in successful cancer
treatment that means going to a doctor
with new scientific methods we can
accurately detect cancer much earlier
than we could even five years ago but in
order to get to a doctor early we must
constantly be on the lookout for cancers
danger Ziggy watch for these any sore
that does not heal a lump or thickening
in the breast or elsewhere unusual
bleeding or discharge any change in a
wart or mold persistent indigestion or
difficulty in swallowing
persistent hoarseness are cost any
change in normal bowel habits thousands
of people are enjoying life today
because they went to their doctor's
early but the fact is that twice as many
people could be cured of cancer every
year if we would all do these things
watch for the danger signals ignore
rumormongers keep away from quacks put
no trust in so-called home remedies for
cancer go to the doctor regularly for
checkups and go immediately when a
symptom shows up that might mean cancer
but here's ed again a few days later
waiting for the results of his
examination alright mr. Parmalee well ed
to hear the answers you've been waiting
ed realizes now how valuable was the
time he wasted in denial sarcasm and
anger worried to get to the point you're
most concerned about the word you do not
have cancer oh I didn't like it doc
you're weeks ago oh boy no more worrying
hold it ed it is foolish to worry day
and night about cancer but it's just as
foolish not to worry about it at all be
on guard don't let fear make a mess of
your life again but use your good common
sense
well Ed's not making the same mistake
twice now he watches for warning signals
goes to a doctor every six months for a
checkup no matter how well he may feel
oh yes and so does Mary
what a difference it makes ensuring
their health their peace of mind and
dispositions ed and Marian are able to
enjoy life to its fullest